so in den in der ersten viertelstunde
dachte ich genau das hat mir so gefehlt
aber es ist wirklich dieses spektakel
heftigkeit des kinos alles was ich für
sie habe ist ein wort
[Musik]
tennet für mich war janet von
christopher nolan der erste film den ich
wieder im kino gesehen habe und dann
eben gleich 70 millimeter imax format
das ist natürlich toll weil das eine
weil das eine zeigt was der auf diesen
kleinen auf diesen kleinen
abspielgeräten eben wirklich nicht
funktioniert und was zumindest bei mir
zu hause auch im sound system nicht
funktioniert ja also der wurm hat da
natürlich noch mal in einer ganz anderen
weise und christopher nolan beherzigt
auf den alten hat das alte hollywood
motto fun mit einer explosion an volkmar
jagd und steigere die ich von dort
wir würden sie dann sterben
sie haben den falschen beruf gewählt
[Musik]
prinzipiell geht es darum dass ein
angriff offenbar geplant ist aus der
zukunft auf die vergangenheit
es gibt menschen in der zukunft die uns
brauchen
damit brauchen und irgendwann kommt dann
hinzu dass alles wirklich ziemlich toll
aussieht also die menschen die männer
hat sind unfassbar schönen gewinnen
frauen sind unfassbar schön die
schauplätze es geht also von oslo über
mumbai nach an die amalfiküste
zwischendurch nach sibirien und new york
und in london wird auch mal mittag
gegessen
also unis ist alles drin so einen einmal
rund um die welt und dann noch mal die
andere richtung
das ist alles hoch befriedigend wenn man
das kino so vermisst hat wie ich das
vermisst habe was ist mir dann aber
letztlich doch fehlt ist eine figur und
das liegt nicht an den darstellen denn
die darstellen sind toll und geben auch
wirklich alles aber immerhin weiß
überhaupt nicht wer ist denn das da
eigentlich
um zu tun was ich tue brauche ich eine
vorstellung von dem was uns droht so wie
ich das verstehe versuchen wir den
dritten weltkrieg zu verhindern
ich sehe hier keine armageddon
[Musik]
etwas schlimmer das heißt ich gucke
diesen spektakel zu und nach einer weile
denke ich was ist das es ist natürlich
ist ja bekannt dass kristoffer moen um
sich in der gewünschten james bond zu
drehen das ist letztlich seien james
bond der so ganz viele viele der
methoden sozusagen oder der wird der
junge elemente des james-bond-films
nacherzählt also es ist sehr bunt lässig
von der gesamten anlage hier nur bei
bond haben wir eine figur die wir kennen
den protagonisten kennen wir nicht ich
finde das sehr schade ich vermute
übrigens dass nach diesem film der von
david washington kein heißer kandidat
ist auf die nachfolge von dem krieg weil
er wirklich so fantastisch ist und eine
solche so die leinwand der hatte ich
beherrscht das ist wirklich toll
ihm zur seite steht robert pattinson als
ein agent der aus irgendeiner
vergangenheit oder zukunft kommt weiß
man nicht so genau
die am beide ungeheure starpower und
insofern tragen die auch natürlich über
diese ganzen doch ziemlich löchrige
geschichte was denken sie ist das alles
die trümmer eines kommenden krieges
christopher nolan ist ein filmemacher
der von seinem ersten film an following
sich damit beschäftigt hat was er
eigentlich mit zeit im kino machen kann
was er mir die zeit manipulieren kann
following ist für mehr ist rückwärts
erzählt jan also da die geschichte geht
vom ende an los zurück zu ihren anfang
damals natürlich noch mit ganz anderen
mitteln euter 200 millionen zur
verfügung um was ähnliches zu machen auf
eine deutliche laboriert
zwischendurch hat er sich vor allen
dingen dadurch namen gemacht dass er
wirklich ein traditionelles das was
seine gewusst was das material angeht er
ist jemand der möglichst nicht auf nicht
digital dreht der möglichst analoges
filmmaterial verwendet möglichst 70 mm
in kombination mit imax also wie das
spektakulärste format das das kino zu
bieten hat benutzt um seine geschichten
zu erzählen
er hat eigentlich immer geschichten
erzählt von inter stähler und und
inception die sich damit beschäftigt
haben wie zeit also mit physikalischen
prozessen die wiwi zeit sich
manipulieren lässt nicht nur im kino
sondern hat eben versuch dazu
geschichten zu finden die die das
plausibel machen
[Musik]
wieso führt durch das so sommer sie
schießen die kugel nicht abhängen
sie fangen sie ein neues kino so gefehlt
hat wie mir der wird mit dem film ganz
gut bedient obwohl der wirklich große
schwächen hat aber er ist eben von seien
in seiner spektakel heftigkeit der dann
doch wieder so befriedigen dass ich
zumindest zu diesem zeitpunkt da auch
drüber weg sehen kann und dann muss ich
habe mich schon ein bisschen so hängen
und so das interesse aber das gehört ja
auch zum kino dazu dass man irgendwie
mal so ein bisschen weg sagt und sich
dann mal für 20 minuten nicht so
interessiert dafür was da so vor sich
geht
ich fand es doch eine tolle erfahrung
wieder wieder im kino zu setzen sei es
mit maske selbst mit großem abstand
in diesem format in diesem format ich
muss gestehen ich habe es für diese
ganzen kammerspiele nicht zurück ins
kino geschafft aber jetzt habe ich doch
gemerkt das hat mir schon ab gefehlt und
wie es ausgeht das heißt wer dann auch
mal so ja ja für wen es nicht so
philosophisch sein muss wie nolan das ja
immer so tut das seine filme so
wahnsinnig philosophisch sperren ich
musste es ja gar nicht haben das
philosophische da bin ich eigentlich
schon sehr zufrieden
sie wollen ein flugzeug löschen lassen
wie groß ist denn das flugzeug
der teil ist vielleicht doch ein wenig
dramatisch